uh hi everybody
so in this in this recording i will
discuss
um so-called deductive methods for
verification
and then shortly
synthesis in hybrid systems and
why we look into hybrid systems we
discussed in the in
an earlier recording i already said that
hybrid systems models
offer a suitable framework
to to to characterize uh
a number of or maybe even
all cyber physical systems and
autonomous systems and other systems of
interest
and the naming of the detective methods
will become
clearer later on in the talk
so um i will mildly
refer to this simple hybrid system model
where we have the state space
and the state space is partitioned into
multiple regions and each region
corresponds to a mode of the system
there is vector field but the vector
field
it may change depending on where we are
for example we might follow a certain
dynamics in
in this region and it may uh
just it refers to this f1
indexed or maybe we should index it with
f
alpha one because it seems like in this
notation we call the mod as alpha one
and it is active only in this region
that corresponds to the
uh to that mode characterized by the
invariant
that that essentially maps uh the label
of the region
to the subset of the continuous state
space where that
that dynamics that that vector field f
alpha one is active
and not surprisingly as we change the
mode
we go to a different region where some
other invariant is active
and now the dynamics becomes f alpha 3
a function of the state and the control
inputs
and uh there might be generalizations of
this
hybrid systems come into very many
different ways
and flavors but just this is
one simple uh model that i will be
sometimes referring to
okay so this is the this is the model
that we will be using and
uh in addition to the uh so we
there are these uh in addition to the
evolution of the dynamics following
these vector fields
we also keep track of uh from what mode
to
a different mode we are jumping as uh
depicted in this
in this with this little uh
arrow here okay so it allows for changes
in the modes and as the
mods change how the system underlying
continuous
dynamics evolve changes okay
so let's remember this one
and then we said um
there are many different approaches for
verification and synthesis for hybrid
system models and
one of the main characteristics that's
different is
this class of models from those that we
study more
heavily in conventionally informal
methods is that for hybrid systems
because of the existence of continuous
state spaces exhaustive search is not
possible
so model checking or reactive synthesis
or anything that relies on finite state
representations will not be
directly applicable and i already
covered
uh quite a bit on this first approach
where we go from
we essentially take the underlying
continuous state space and discretize it
into finite human states
and try to approximate the underlying
continuous evolution by a finite state
model
and we use that for synthesis purposes
in this recording i'm going to look into
this these deductive techniques
and as i said before i will not cover
much about these
exposed construction of the reachable
sets and keeping track of where the
system might go and whether
it might get into trouble
um okay so
when we want to talk about verification
or synthesis one of the first things
that we need to clear is
perhaps what's for what specifications
what is the purpose of it
and i'm going to discuss a couple of
specifications
uh that are that that's
that will become useful um
and i will grow this later to more
general uh
more general subsets of temporal logic
like statements
or continuous state spaces obviously
that that statement needs to be made
clear so we have this hybrid system
model
sorry
we have the hybrid system model given
here
and this notation is going to represent
the solution of the
underlying dynamics at time t
starting from the initial condition x is
zero
and um x the initial condition may
represent the initial mod and the
initial state but
for the given simple model uh if we
if we fix the initial condition for the
continuous
state space it also determines the
initial mode so there's a little bit of
simplification there
not that it is too important so one of
the
temporal properties that controls has
been
studying pretty heavily is stability
and for that we have an equilibrium
condition or some fixed
solution of the underlying differential
equations
and then we start from some initial
condition or it could belong to some
uh subset of the state space and we are
interested in whether
all solutions that start from the set of
initial conditions will converge to the
equilibrium condition
or that fixed solution as time grows
so that's the stability and safety
roughly can be characterized as given
some unsafe set there's a
there's a set of subsets of the states
that we don't want to enter
for example this set here we are
starting from x0
the question is whether there uh
we will call the system safe if there
exists no
time it is called t unsafe here
such that the initial conditions that
the solutions the initial conditions in
the set x0
enter enter the unsafe set
at time on t unsafe
so this roughly saying that there is no
initial condition and there is no finite
time within which
the system will start from this green
set and will go and enter the red sets
reachability is now there is a point
that
there's a set that we are not
necessarily trying to avoid we want to
enter it
and the reachability looks into the
question whether there is one solution
that starts from x0 and it will do
something and it will reach it will it
will come to x
x sub reach within a certain amount of
time that we call t sub reach
in this in this characterization and
it's just going to grow
eventually essentially is whether
reachability holds
for all initial conditions uh
in the initial set and we can combine
these properties and
write relatively complicated
specifications for example if you have
three sets we might look into starting
from some set whether we will reach two
other sets but
uh we would not want to enter one region
without
um without first going through some
other region
and all sorts of combinations as part
possible and it is going to build up
toward
the type of properties at least the way
that we hear them
that we encounter in subsets of temporal
logic
and we will get to that okay so we will
look into these specifications and
or these are typical specifications that
we encounter in more conventional
studies of study on deductive methods
for hybrid systems or
dynamical systems and if i'm not
mistaken in these slides i will refer to
the safety property
more often than the others okay so what
does a deductive method do
this is going to be for verification
purposes and i'm going to
have a few comments for uh for synthesis
generalization to synthesis
so if you remember the safety property
holds for
um and i'm going to look into just a
pure
continuous dynamics there are no mods in
this
enable i will point out to the
distinction between
purely continuous dynamics and hybrid
dynamics in the next slide
so if you remember we will call the
system
to hold the safety property if there
exists no time
t and no trajectory such that starting
from x0
within that time t we enter the unsafe
set and we
stay inside the inside the inside state
space
so we want to check this property
whether for a given dynamical system
this property holds or not
and deductive methods do not necessarily
try to
directly answer that question instead
they try to check something
related and one example here is that
we will try to check if there exists a
differentiable function b
b is from the state space
where x to
reals and it is going to have a few
properties
in the initial sets we want this thing
to be b to b less than or equal to zero
and in the unsafe set x sub u in this
slide we want b to be greater than zero
and everywhere in the in the state space
everywhere we want b dot to be less than
or equal to zero that means if b starts
uh less than or equal to zero since its
derivative along the trajectories
b dot here is b that is
the uh the gradient of um
sorry the gradient of b with respect to
x
times the vector field so it is the rate
of change in b
along the trajectories of the dynamics
right
following the trajectories of dynamics
this b cannot
start less than or equal to zero and
ever become
greater than zero right strictly greater
than zero that's going to mean
if i start somewhere in this i am less
than or equal to zero
i cannot grow hence i cannot enter
i cannot enter this this region ever
right i can
i can leave it i can wander around but i
can never enter this unsafe region then
obviously if we can somehow verify that
this statement holds if we can
find such a function b then it's going
to imply that
the safety property holds right and
therefore we can't call
if we can't find such a function b we
can call that to witness
uh the safety property for this
underlying dynamical system for given
sets
x0 and xu etc uh
and there depending on what property we
try to verify
and what kind of a function we try to
construct
that there are different names for these
functions and for this particular case
it is typically called a barrier
certificate
because essentially um
this is the set is sorry the function is
less than zero here
greater than zero here there is a sub
level set
of the function b is equal to zero
uh along the trajectories of the system
we can never cross
across the b equal to zero therefore
that
is a barrier between the initial set of
states
and the uh the unsafe set of states so
if we can find b
then fine we will have solved our
verification problem and if we cannot
find such a b
then uh then uh we cannot say much
uh because this th this arrow is only
one direction
there is no we don't have this direction
okay
and actually we haven't even spoken
about how we ever can
go and algorithmically search for a
function like this
so uh i'm going to quickly go through
now
uh the flow that's a typical flow for
for
search for a barrier certificate or a
search for
algebraic witnesses algebraic functions
that witness the
specifications against dynamical systems
through deductive methods so we want to
answer a question whether
a given system is safe or not that's the
starting point
and we say no we cannot answer that but
we say if we can't find
sorry so we want to answer
this question but if we say we get
that's too hard i'm not going to try to
answer that
instead i'm going to go and look for a
function b that satisfies certain
properties
and the point is that
um
if we can answer this then there is this
one-sided implication
but typically searching for a general
class for a function
from a general class of functions that
satisfy certain properties as hard
and we will say look that's too hard for
me um
let's go and um let's go and change that
question a little bit
all right and instead of going and
imposing b is less than 0 for all x in
some set
we will say that you know what let me
actually relax that condition and
instead of
of looking for a function that satisfies
those i'm going to look for a function
that is
minus b minus some positive other
function
some other function is that is positive
non-negative and i am going to represent
this set x0 through some
for example the set of states x
that are in x zero is going to be
represented by
this function g sub zero and the set x
zero is going to be the set of states or
set of points for which
g of zero is greater than zero so for
each set that we encounter for
x sub u and x etc we'll go and represent
them
through uh these inequalities over
uh on on on given functions
so then the point is if we can go and
find
uh if we can go and verify whether this
statement holds or not
that's a witness for this statement
and then obviously we will have this
this implication as well
typically that's even hard then we say
you know what
searching for through general families
of functions is hard
i'm going to go ahead and search for
over some polynomials
of certain degree all right i'm going to
look for
look for this b within the polynomials
up to some degree
quadratics fourth order polynomials
whatever
so and obviously that this is not
equivalent to this one but there is a
one-sided implication
if if i can find such polynomials that's
going to be an indication that some
function exists
etc but not the other way around uh if
there's no
polynomial that satisfies given
conditions there might still be
functions from a more general family of
functions that might satisfy the
conditions i cared about in this box
and then the story goes on like that so
okay polynomials but these are now
inequalities over polynomials a hard
question to answer
you may relax that as well and go ahead
and impose
so-called sum of squares optimization or
some
other forms of semi-definite programming
typically that
more conventionally run into these
things but it doesn't have to be that so
somehow you actually relax even further
so that
uh there is a decision procedure that we
can apply to
uh search for uh these witnesses
and where if if we cannot if we cannot
answer this question
that this very final question that we
are intending to answer
it does not say much about whether the
first
the actual question that we want to
answer through deductive verification
was answerable or not
we might have lost listing any point
in this flow because every step we are
actually making the
search more restrictive more restricted
more restrictive and if
if this did if we cannot answer this at
this point
then we can ask whether we could have
done anything better
for this one-sided implication for this
one-sided implication for this one-sided
for this one-sided implication on that
and we can later discuss what that means
uh so deductive verification techniques
if there if
you can create a positive a formative
answer that's good if you cannot then
then you need to go and look into
the steps that you have taken and try to
see where
things might have gone wrong and
obviously one of the explanations is
that indeed this question
did not have an affirmative answer but
except for very special cases where all
these one-sided implications are
actually indeed two-sided
and they are very rare cases
in which that that happens uh unless you
are in one of those cases
um then uh then
then it is a it becomes a little bit of
trial and error so it is we can
even call that the nanoformative answer
is inconclusive
in in these deductive techniques okay
so that is the general flow the the
the question that you might want to
answer could change
the the sufficient condition that you
invoke
might change the way that you actually
parametrize and deal with
things might change and the way that you
try to solve instead of using some other
programming we might go and use a
different decision procedure
but this is roughly the general general
flow
so how do things change when we have
hybrid dynamics
and on this on the left i'm repeating
what we had in the previous slide and on
the right i am showing
just one instance where things will be
changing different
so we are imposing these conditions on
the
on the on the function b uh the first
one for all states in x0
the second one for all states in xu etc
now for each mode for each mode we will
introduce one of these
barrier certificates appropriately
smooth functions for each mode and then
we will go and impose similar conditions
we want the b
to be less than or equal to zero but we
want the b sub l
within the within the mode l we want
that function to be less than or equal
to zero
and then that that not for all x in x0
but we take the intersection with
the set of states where that mode is
active so i if
if x0 is in in this in this
a set like that and then for the first
one
b sub alpha one we want b sub alpha one
to be less than zero or equal to zero
only in this part not the entire x zero
and the story goes on like that
the second condition was on x sub u and
now we restrict
it to be within the mod and x sub u
similarly this derivative condition is
in the same way
and then we have one more restriction on
these things which is
if we ever jump from mode l l
prime sorry l to l prime if there is a
mod switch from
l to l prime within which
uh when that happens if f
for whatever reason a discrete jump on x
zero also happens
we want uh we want
the b to be decreasing or not increasing
across those uh jumps as well so let's
say there is no jump
we have a smooth transition
through this point upon to
up until this point b sub
alpha one was active and then right
after that point
b sub alpha 3 becomes active so we don't
want the value of in b
from b sub alpha 1 to b sub alpha 3
to jump all right we don't want that to
increase as this last condition takes
care of these discrete
transitions and this is typically how
these more control theoretic techniques
actually keep track of the discrete
jumps in the dynamics
and um and you can imagine if if there
are
many of these discrete jumps possible
then these conditions will become pretty
pretty complicated okay
so this is this is the idea behind
deductive verification how do we use
these things for synthesis
let me go back first so instead of
having
synthesis is going to refer to in this
context instead of having this
i'm going to have x dot is equal to f of
x
and u and i'm going to ask you know what
can i find some control signal
u that's going to keep me safe right
hence we can take all these things
and in addition to what conditions we
have we can go and qualify
whether there exists some signal you
that is going to make
all these conditions hot and
and you can try it uh conceptually
that approach is going to go through and
there are lots of papers that try to do
that and
try to pull different tricks to make
these resulting conditions
a little bit more manageable i'm going
to refer to that as
looking directly into synthesis through
deductive methods
conceptually there's nothing wrong but
computationally even the verification
problems are relatively complicated
so that approaches becomes even more
computationally demanding um
and then there are lots of
different ways of using uh these ideas
indirectly the verification ideas
indirectly uh
one of them is called so-called control
the open functions
and the dynamics are given in this
control a fine form
and then the
it reads as uh if there exists a
function
v similar to various certificates but
this
in this case it is we are concerned in
this one example little example here we
are concerned with the stability of the
dynamics
of the system and the question is we are
asking is whether
we can find a control signal u
that is going to stabilize the dynamics
around equilibrium
at x equal to zero then the sufficient
condition reads us
if there exists a function v that along
with some other
technical conditions satisfies this
statement
we want the partial derivative of v
with respect to x times g this part of
the dynamics to be equal to zero
at all points that are not equal to zero
that not an equilibrium point we want
that thing to imply
that the partial derivative of v with
respect to x
along the uh the direction of
f f of x to be less than zero so
whenever
this thing vanishes roughly we want this
thing to be less than zero
if we can't find the v that satisfies
this condition
then then we can actually
uh construct a controller from the
knowledge of v
we can construct a stabilizing control
we can take that controller
plug it into here and then we will have
a proof that actually this time
these dynamics will close the dynamics
will be stable
around the equilibrium point and if you
look at this one
through some um through some
tricks we can you can see that actually
this does not necessarily refer to the
control input you directly so
control the open of functions uh figure
out a way
of a relation between the derivative of
we with respect to x in the direction of
f and in the direction of g such that if
the function v satisfies that relation
then
we can find a control signal u out of
the knowledge of v
that's going to stabilize the system so
that
that obviously makes the problem easier
than directly explicitly
introducing the u into the algebraic
conditions that we have and qualifying
those statements with respect to
the existence of the control signal u
another approach to you that relies on
deductive methods probably is
a little bit more indirect i did not
know what to call it i call it indirect
methods but
essentially uh
to a certain extent ignoring the
underlying dynamics
these methods typically find a nominal
trajectory that satisfies
the the high level requirements that you
might have in mice
and then they ask the question of
if i ever find myself not along those
nominal trajectory
can i find a more can i solve a more
local
localized and hopefully a simpler uh
verification question
which is if i if my system starts from
this point
am i going to go and get and approach
this nominal trajectory that i want to
follow
and you may ask it from many different
conditions so
do i have a controller the controller
has already been designed
or you can you can rely on simple
control techniques for linear systems
and ask the question if i use a given
controller or a
controller that is designed for the
linearization of dynamics along this
nominal trajectory and if i find myself
away from this
nominal trajectory that i want to follow
am i going to go back to this nominal
trajectory
and obviously you try to cover through a
bunch of questions
as much space around your nominal
trajectory as you can
so that if you ever find yourself off a
nominal trajectory
you'll try to go back to that and doing
that
you will be able to uh you will be able
to satisfy the high level requirements
that you had in mind
and the nominal trajectory remember was
chosen with those high level
requirements that we wanted to satisfy
so that this is essentially
there is no direct synthesis per se
using a deductive method here
but somehow you come up with something
that you want to follow and you try to
use the detective techniques to
certify that your closed dynamics will
be able to follow
that and that is going to be a
transition to a little bit more
um a trend this this is a transition
point where how we can actually go and
introduce
more temporal logic type specifications
and i am not going to get into details
of this but let me at least
set up the problem so we have continuous
dynamics
not necessarily now um
hybrid dynamics with mod switchings etc
we will end up having a hybrid
uh dynamical system but for a different
reason
so um we have that then we introduce
this
labeling function essentially um
it is the label of this it
represents the set membership over this
continuous state space
we have here x so the label that
a holds if we're in this set label c
halls if you're in this set etcetera all
right so
and we can think these things uh these
labels as
uh just the indicators of this the
regions in the state space that we care
about we may want to enter them we may
want we may start from them we may not
reach that we may want to reach them we
may
want to uh just do to do it in some
order etcetera so we
we will represent the properties that we
care
in terms of these labels and the labels
will correspond to the set membership
over the continued state space
and this is going to introduce
essentially if we take
a trajectory that starts here
at time time time t 0 obviously
none of abc holds up until here now
a is holding until this nothing is
holding
b is holding nothing is holding c is
holding and nothing is holding along the
trajectory
we can then introduce so what we will
call a the discrete behavior of the
system which is essentially the sequence
of labels that we'll be holding
along the trajectory um
and then we will go and use a cross-safe
temporal logic specification
and uh and then to to grant these things
a little bit
more we will have a finite a final state
and we will have a finite time
all right um so that is the point and
the problem that we will try to solve
the model is given
the specification is going to be
represented as a as a
finite state deterministic automaton and
then
uh then we will try to compute a control
value that is going to minimize this
something over the continuous state and
the inputs
and then we will keep track of the
switches in the in the uh in the states
of the automaton
and then we may introduce some
cost of mode transition as well and then
we at the final time we will try to come
to this final state that we care
and in addition to that we want a
discrete behavior of the system
to satisfy the the cossack tempo logic
specification we have we want
the discrete behavior to be in the
language of the this automaton that
corresponds to the specifications that
is given
so this is the this is the question
in the in the hierarchical control
recording that i
posted we looked into a problem like
this and what we did was
we took the continuous dynamics and then
we discretized them
uh to a finite state representation and
then applied the reactive synthesis
tools or
or model checking or whatever the
appropriate question that we're asking
in the tool from formal methods once we
have the continuous
sorry finite state representation for
this site
we could go and check that against the
given specification
using a an appropriate tool from from
formal methods
here we will not do that we will do
something slightly different so
as you can see once we compose these two
systems now we have a hybrid system
on the left we have
on the left we have a continuous
dynamics
the u is to be determined and then uh
we have uh discrete modes on the right
hand side that will keep track
of the evolution with respect to the
underlying specification
and what's going to happen is we will
search for a dynamic programming based
solution for this problem essentially we
we can introduce this thing called
vbstar it is the optimal cost to go
subject to specifications
and what we will do is uh while the the
labels remain constant
and then we will also separate look into
our discrete transitions so when
when the mods random mode of the system
stays the same
so we enter the region of interest and
while we are in that
we will impose a condition like this we
want
the u that we are looking for to
minimize this expression here
and more transition here corresponds to
now i am leaving one region the labels
are changing
when the labels are changing we want to
transition to a new mode
that minimizes this expression here
and uh and then the quantification here
is over what
discrete mode we are in and what the
corresponding underlying continuous
set of continuous states are and um and
similarly
here what the discrete transition that
we are taking and
over what uh continuous states this is
happening and
we also impose this at the terminal
state that we
specified we want this v star to be less
than zero
so if we can find a v star that
satisfies all these
then we will have a solution for the
problem
and this is this is by itself pretty
complicated problem
instead of that we will go and now relax
these things and we will look for a
approximate value function that is going
to be an underestimator
of the actual value function instead we
try to find the optimal value function
we will find an under approximator for
that
and the conditions for searching an
under approximator this is the original
condition we had in the previous slide
we will relax these things and um
and look for this so a v that satisfies
this inequality
and then at the same when the labels are
the same
when the label switches we will we will
impose this condition and the terminal
condition again holds first
under approximately and still
this is pretty hard problem but this is
now this has
a relatively similar flavor to the
conditions that started looking into
when we had a verification problem for
safety properties
we are searching for a function v and we
want
this combination this this linear
map from v to be greater than
zero for all x's and
u's and q while these
x u and q belong to some pre-specified
sets
and similarly uh we have uh
similar conditions so we are searching
for v and we want v to satisfy certain
property while
we are in some set or while we satisfy
some other property but
these are similar conditions that we are
trying to impose
in on the search of v so
they look much different and possibly
more complicated
but at a high level they are similar
conditions that we have encountered
in deductive verification for safety
property example that we looked into
so i'm gonna then i'm not going to get
into how we can actually solve these
things
but similar flow from hey i cannot solve
this here's a lower approximation
i cannot do it let me go and search in
some uh
in some smaller family of functions
polynomials quadratics whatever
let me go and try to formulate as an
optimization problem to try to solve it
if i can solve it i'm going to go up now
i have a solution if i cannot solve it
i know just if we will need to go and
improve one of these steps
all right so this is that let me and
then once we have the
v out of that we can actually construct
the control input that's going to that's
going to uh
that's going to achieve what we wanted
to achieve and
uh and and this last piece is
essentially saying that let's
parametrize in some finite form and then
can go and try to formulate a control
problem out of that
so let me just look at one little
example
we have this um we have this
uh continuous dynamics with a and b so
essentially we have x dot is equal to ax
plus bu
and the cost function is from 0 to t
x transpose x plus
u transpose u
dt and then
i believe this this is this is the
coefficient that we have for the mod
switch
so just one times i'm like i'm going to
write it more switch cost
so this is the relative relative
weight that we put into mod switching
and then the specification is
um whenever we start in a we eventually
want to reach b
whenever we start in c eventually reach
b and eventually a
or eventual c and then here's the
solution
and then one thing that i will point to
in the solution is
it's it shows two different trajectories
starting from d
and starting from a let's look at what
happens when we start from d
so we are in region b
okay and
starting from there what we need to do
is we
actually eventually either reach a or
eventually reach c so we cannot go and
converge to the equilibrium point that's
a terminal condition in this case
so eventually at the end we want to go
to the state
but we can't just do this we can't take
this path to it
so we need to actually first starting
from the region b
we need to go away from it either to a
or c and the trajectory does that it
first
goes to a and now once it
goes to a it says okay now i can go back
and it starts to go back
and the thing that we need to notice is
both of these points
are in the region b but the underlying
system actually behaves
relatively differently when we are in
this region at this point in b
we first it pushes us away and then
once we actually go ahead and visit a
and come back now the system remembers
because we have been keeping track of
these modes right
now this is the number okay i'm coming
from a now there is nothing wrong with
me going and
now terminating at this uh
x is equal to zero right so this is
essentially what this
keeping track of the moles through this
product construction between the
underlying continuous dynamics and the
discrete modes brings to us and if you
look at the
closed loop dynamics within each mode we
will see that
when we start here we actually
correspond to this small in the discrete
transitions
in the in the finite state of amazon but
when we come to
uh region b again we are now in this
mode
and indeed uh in the same region b
when you are in mod q4 you this on
continuous dynamics is stable
but if you are in the in region b but in
mod
q0 the dynamics are actually unstable
close the dynamics unstable
so uh this is how to interpret the
results
and and and it is going to generalize to
any underlying dynamics
so any underlying specification that
belongs to the
class of code safe temporal logic
specifications
okay now a little summary of deductive
verification and synthesis techniques
uh so we typically uh start with
a system theoretical question is my
system stable safe satisfies some type
of like specification
and this is a question over this the
behavior of the system
right just we have the state space and
how my system behaves in that state
space
we transform it to a search for an
algebraic function
that will witness the satisfaction of
the system to verify property
it could be depending on what we are
asking the operator function the rear
function value function whatever
and this is now this has nothing to do
with the underlying system
it isn't it is it is just some
conditions
are a function of b that we are
searching for
all right given the dynamics given the
sets that we have
it does not even know that there is an
underlying system anymore
and if we can answer it there is a
solution and this is
hard to answer and therefore we try to
translate these things through
certain relaxations or equivalences etc
we try to translate this into an
optimization based search or
construction
for these witnesses and depending on
what kind of dynamics you have what kind
of question you're asking and
what kind of tools that you might want
to um use
how you represent these underlying
functions etc
we might and we might end up using
different optimization
routines or interfaces to optimization
routines
uh on control sites obviously convex
optimization have been used very heavily
but if the underlying dynamics are con
piece files are fine
and and and if you are searching for
piece wise i find
uh certificates for these properties
there's nothing wrong with going and
trying to invoke
a and try to use an underlying smt solar
for search of these things and this
actually opens up
the the the detective techniques that
uh typically have been involved in on
the control site to actually
pretty interesting problems you could
you could
there are increasing examples for
example on the underlying dynamics are
piecewise effing and we have a neural
network that has
uh piecewise found non-linearities
so-called rayleigh
non-linearities in the neural network
and the you can take the close the
dynamics between them
and the resulting thing is going to be a
humongous piecewise defined
uh representation and how you can ask
similar verification questions
conceptually very much possible uh the
computational limitations
are that's probably the research where
we
the field needs to think a little bit
more uh okay this is where i'm going to
stop for this recording
uh thank you for listening and i'm happy
to discuss these things over the
course of this program